la semaine dernière l'heure est grave il
20h10 on est en direct
j'avais dit
que
cela la semaine dernière
j'avais dit j'avais dit rappelez vous
dans cette émission en direct j'avais
dit je ne ferai pas jamais super je ne
ferai jamais la une de paris match je ne
la ferai pas et hanoune a des
convictions
à loi va au bout de ses idées
résultat
je suis tranquillement chez moi tout à
l'heure et qu'est-ce qu'on m'envoie
cyril hanouna
alors je veux bien passer pour un con
mais au moins qu'on me prévienne avant
non mais voilà donc en fait je vais vous
raconter toute l'histoire en cs je fais
une interview avec l'excellent bruno
jeudy de paris match vraiment super gars
pour la sortie de mon livre vous avez
qui sortira le 6 octobre voilà comme on
dit
c'est un livre je vous raconterai plus
amplement mais surtout ce qui s'est
passé sur le plateau tous les gens que
j'ai rencontrés sur le plateau je vous
donne énormément de coulisses de ce qui
se passe et notamment dans ce livre je
parle de mes relations avec certains
hommes politiques puisqu'on en a reçu
beaucoup ici et il y en a un que je
téléphone voilà que je dis non dans le
livre donc l'interview est vraiment top
bruno jeudy top et le titre donc devient
cyril hanouna conseiller ce credo macron
sa première interview politique alors
les gens petit voilà qu'on me dise à
nous n'est pas mal en blonde
mais et donc c'est devenu hanoune a
conseillé secret de mâcon
alors je parle aussi bien des gilet
jaune se parle énormément d gilet jaune
dans le livre et vous le savez je les ai
jamais cachées outils j'ai une tendresse
particulière pour les gilet jaune parce
que je les ai vus énergie et il ya
beaucoup de gilet jaune avec qui je suis
resté proche et que voilà qui m'ont
amené énormément de choses et qui m'ont
appris plein de choses sur ce qu'ils
vivent et et comme je le dis à chaque
fois neuf gilet jaune sur dix c'est
vraiment juste un français comme nous
comme vous enfin et un français qui est
pâques parce que nous on a la chance
d'être ici tous les jours est à voir et
de pouvoir vivre franchement des comme
des privilégiés mais il ya beaucoup de
français qui sont en galère et les gilet
jaune c'est avant tout des français en
galère 9 sur 10 après il y en a un sur
voilà c'est pas de gilet jaune
d'ailleurs les casseurs ce sont d'autres
mecs qui ont du semi raid gillet et qui
sont dits gilet jaune mais qui sont
voilà qui sont là pour [ __ ] la merde
et je parle des gilet jaune je parle des
gens que je dis que m'entends bien avec
jean luc mélenchon même si voilà je suis
je suis opposé à lui sur pleins d'idées
c'est vrai que notre temps plutôt bien
avec lui vous le savez ça a été ça n'a
jamais été un secret pour personne et je
dis également que je peux avoir le
président emmanuel macron par sms ou
voilà au téléphone sur certaines choses
comme je peux avoir xavier bertrand joue
dit au téléphone ou de visu comme je
peux avoir je vous dit jean luc
mélenchon raquel garrido voilà d'autres
d'autre part d'autres personnalités
politiques et donc le titre c'est devenu
si rennes m'a conseillé ce crime voilà
donc voilà donc la sexy ouais c'est
parti ces vendeurs normal c'est prendre
c'est pourquoi mais voilà oui la bague
ont donc voilà comment voilà donc voilà
donc l'interview est très bien réelle
mais se voit là ils ont fait un
raccourci oui voilà qui montre que je
suis circoncis
et c'est une première exactement la
première fois qu'un petit empiète sur le
visage
le corps
[Applaudissements]
si je vous parlerai du livre vous
parlerai de ce cadeau je vous dis je
serai invité touche pas à mon poste
prochainement on parle et
vous alors si un petit peu court sur le
sérieux pour l'argent je vous
expliquerai non mais c'est vrai donc
merci à vous et vous verrez je livre
plein de coulisses c'est vrai voilà et
je parle également médecin de marlène
schiappa voilà du grand débat chaud
parle de tout ce qui s'est passé dans
l'émission et je parle également voilà
de tous les sujets qui ont pu fâcher
dans cette émission il revient dessus
avec christophe barbier voilà qui est un
journaliste que j'adore vous savez un
éditorialiste très très compétente c'est
ce qu'il fallait parce que c'est vrai
que je vais vous dire c'est lui qui a
retranscrit tout ce que j'ai dit et mon
fils il a trouvé le livre chez moi et
c'est lui qui a retranscrit donc moi je
vais raconter tout ce qu'ils racontent
dedans c'est de moi c'est vrai c'est
vraiment que des choses voilà je vous
dis 100% vrai 100% authentique et et
100% coulisses et plateaux et ils ont
ils ont regardé je vous dis quatre ans
des missions pour faire ce livre toutes
les émissions quattron voilà donc c'est
un travail énorme qui ont fait les
équipes d'isabelle saporta et là monfils
prend le livre il commence à dire comme
ça et c'est donc christophe barbier qui
a retranscrit et il y n'y fait
[Rires]
mais papa ne sait pas du tout quoi qui
écrit son histoire
vraie donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
c'est très bien écrit parce que
christophe a très bien retranscrit ce
que je lui disais mais on retrouve bien
entendu toutes les anecdotes et ma façon
quand même de raconter des choses en
tout cas ça sort le 6 octobre voilà et
c'est vrai que voilà cc c'est un truc de
fou je vous en parlerai plus tard